-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#ItShouldBeIllegalTo stories
from you guys.
This first one here is
from @WantPeace4All.
That's nice.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
You still look the same, Karen
This one's from @CJ7Ten.
-Ooh, CJ7Ten.
-He's 7'10".
He's like a gentle giant.
-Yeah, 710. 7'10".
-He says...
"Leave me alone!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you!
Power saver mode on your TV.
-Leave me be.
This is from @lissyisbusy.
-Oh, she is.
[ Laughter ]
She's very busy.
-She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's simple math!
-Illegal.
-This one's from @dontatme..
-Oh, well, then don't.
[ Laughter ]
-...30. She says...
[ Applause ]
No, actually we only do --
Sorry, we only do --
-Chips?
-What's that?
No, we only check your swipes.
-Okay, so I should swipe it.
-No, we take checks.
-Wait, you take checks?
-Just put the chip in
and wait for the beep.
Don't remove it.
-Okay, wait a second.
-Don't take it out!
Seriously, a lot of screwed-up
things will happen.
-I'm not gonna take it out
-Oh, aisle four
was just destroyed.
Please stop touching the chip.
-Alright, I'm taking it --
-You got to sign it.
You have to sign it.
You have to pay for the person
behind you as well.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Megan18495602
Very easy.
How come you never tweet me,
you idiot?
-Well, why don't you
just tweet me --
-Just do -- it's so simple
-Okay, what's your name
on Twitter?
-@Jimmy24191949 -- sorry, 1-5-3.
You're, like, not my friend.
I'm unfollowing you.
-No, I'll get it.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
Give it to me again.
One more time.
-What were you just doing?
-I was erasing numbers.
-Were you on WhatsApp?
-I was on my calculator.
I was writing on --
[ Laughter ]
I was on the wrong app.
I just learned how to eras
on a calculator.
3-5-8-4.
-Just do it the way
in the rhythm.
2-3-4, blah, blah, blah.
-Yeah.
-Don't do it in twos.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's my number.
9-7, 3-6-4.
-1-9, 1-4.
-Wait, what?
How am I supposed to --
-1-1-1-9-9-1-1-1-9-1-1.
[ Laughter ]
-4-8-4-8-9-3-8-7.
-This is from @Megan18495602 -
-Empire.
[ Laughter ]
-She says...
No, come on, hey.
-Hey, come on.
-Come on.
-Come on, front butt.
That's rude.
-This one's from
@AGillenwater98.
-AGillenwater98?
-Not Jillen Water.
-Gillenwater?
-Oh, Gillenwater.
-A -- This is from
AGillenwater98.
-A gill in water? Maybe it's
like a fish reference.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
No -- Gillen, G-I-L-L-E-N.
-Like Gilligan
from "Gilligan's Island"?
-No, that's Gilligan,
as, like, you just said.
So, it's Gillen.
But I see where
you made the mistake.
-Yeah, yeah, I made the mistake.
I misheard.
I thought you said Gilligan.
-You thought that I said
"Gilligan's Island."
-Yes.
-Instead I said AGillenwater98
-Well, Gilligan lives, is --
he's surrounded by water.
-No spoilers.
I've never seen the show.
-Are you serious?
[ Laughter ]
Alright,
I don't want to ruin it.
They go for a three-hour cruise.
-Is that where they go
and their fantasies happen
Just don't spoil it.
This is from @AGillenwater98
He says...
-Oh, cold-blooded.
[ Applause ]
-Then you're in Satan's hands.
-Yeah, oh.
-This one's from @margesondanny.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Illegal!
-I signed customer copy!
-This last one's
from @mariabrandont.
She says...
-Oh!
-There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#HowIGotDumped
stories from you guys.
Here we go. This first one's
from @kyleosmon.
He said...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
It's like, "What's going on?
-Wake up!
-This ones from @ItsNotTheFall
"It's not the fall"?
Is that a famous thing?
It's not --
It's not the fall.
Talking about seasons?
[ Laughter ]
It's not the fall that hurts..
-It's the coffee?
The bunk?
The rehab?
[ Laughter ]
It's not the fall,
it's the rehab.
-I'm thinking skiing.
I'm thinking skiing.
-Oh, I was thinking
falling from grace, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, you were thinking
fall from grace.
-Yeah, like, you know,
you hit rock bottom,
you have to go to rehab.
Something like that, whatever.
[ Laughter ]
-Everything okay, man?
-Nah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sleeping on my couch
in the office.
-We'll talk about this later
We shouldn't say this --
shouldn't do it
on national television.
This is from @ItsNotTheFall.
She -- She says...
[ Audience groans ]
[ Wah-wah! ]
-Oh, come on!
-It's not the fall.
-Yeah, not the fall.
-Holy moly.
If that ever happened...
Wow, wow, wow.
This one's from @NotGlue.
[ Laughter ]
-Not the fall and not glue
-Not glue.
That's not glue, dude.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Andrew Karn.
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"I had nothing to do --"
-There's other stuff going on.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @matadorchick
-Ooh.
Nice. No bull.
-She likes matadors.
-Yeah.
-She says...
[ Laughter ]
What?
-That's it.
-Well, folks,
that's the ball game.
-Lates.
-[ Chuckles ]
This one's from @Ash10G.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Wow!
Wow!
♪♪♪♪
Wow.
-Ouch!
-This last one's
from @kalsimanmeet.
He says...
There you have it!
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#WhyDidISayThat tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from @mopage19.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @TheMostKing4.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Which town?
-This one's from @teenager423.
He says...
-Yeah.
-This one's from @RobynProctor1.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
I like montofri.
-Oh.
-Let's try it.
-I've had that.
I usually don't like it.
-I like fried food.
-I love montos.
-I love montos, yeah.
This one's from @kristennd
She says...
"I was trying on the shirt
I own these."
-I meant...
-Oh, this is a good one.
This one's from @kingedhill.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
"I want extra fries.
You know what?
Make that two extra fries.
You listening to me?"
[ Laughter ]
-"You're not listening to me
-It was a garbage can.
This last one's from @lweaveee
She says...
There you go.
He's up twice.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags